hey there everyone welcome to folding
ideas in the second part of our
discussion of source code so now this
week we're going to do a little bit
differently we're going to try and do it
you know just just a bit off the cuff
what we're going to be looking at here
isn't so much something that you really
are going to get from the text it's more
something that you've got a you've got
to dig in a bit and make a bit of
speculation you know we're just going to
have some fun so this is the dark side
of source code so last week when we were
talking about source code we spent most
of the time talking about captain Colter
Stevens and how he fits into everything
we actually need to talk about someone
else Sean Fentress the ending of source
code is more or less a happy one you
know boy gets girl they walk off into
well not the sunset but they walk off
into the they stand in front of the
cloud gate it's giant mirrored sculpture
it looks cool they get to do their
little thing and then and then comes the
ending and this is what we didn't
actually talk about but while he was on
the train after he stopped after he
stopped Derrick frost he called his dad
but he also sent an email and he sent an
email to the captain crap what's her
name crap crap why don't I remember this
good one
he sent the he sent the email to captain
Goodwin well not not the same captain
Goodwin that we were hanging out with he
actually sent an email to the captain
Goodwin of of this universities in now
or this reality see with the ending of
source code what happens is there's the
whole moment where Goodwin shuts off his
life-support back in back in the main
reality and he keeps going and this
basically this confirms that in fact
source code does does actually transfer
between between solid realities these
realities don't just exist within the
eight minutes of source code they are
completely different timelines that are
self-contained they exist and so he's
sending it off to this alternate
universe version of good
and this route version of Goodwin this
universe is good when they also have a
source code project and they have a
culture Stevens who's also in you know
he also got blown up in Afghanistan and
he's plugged into a machine this creates
some interesting moral implications you
see for almost every version that was
created almost every universe that was
created things didn't really change all
that much in reality prime obviously
things changed or identified Derek Frost
as the bomber in the white panel van and
he got that he got the license plate
number and all of that stuff in all but
two of the other ones things didn't
really change I mean they went poorly
but everybody died on the train except
for two things don't really work out too
well for for the girl because they get
off the train he takes her off the train
and then dies but he doesn't just die
like he he gets hit by by the cargo
train that's coming the other direction
you know he's he's down on the tracks
and he's like uh I can't get up and then
the train and she's all like no get out
of the way and he's like what and then
he's like oh no train BAM so so in this
universe which keep in mind is its own
continuity he's actually made things
worse for this girl I mean sure she's
still alive
but before he died before he got hit by
that train he told her like hey crazy
crap is gonna go down and like there's
gonna be all kinds of like messed-up
stuff happening and I can see the future
and just trust me like I've got a really
bad feeling so he tells her I've got a
really bad feeling we should get off
this train and then you know six minutes
later that train blows up and so now
this woman and and this is kind of where
we've got to go back and we've got to
start talking about we've got to start
talking about the teacher we need to
address this whole thing with Sean
Fentress so so let's look at this girl
and let's look at her relationship to
Sean Fentress so Sean Fentress was a
teacher and these two are colleagues of
some kind now she just quit her job and
is moving on from a relationship and his
track you know he's making some big life
changes but they know each other and
they're good friends and
got a she's got a huge crush on him and
she's been waiting forever for Sean not
Coulter to ask her out for coffee she
wants to go on a date with him but she's
waiting for him to make the first move
so they ride the train together all the
time and they know each other really
well and they're good friends and she
wants to get it on with him and then all
of a sudden he starts acting a little
bit differently and he's like oh I got
this crazy feeling we need to get off
this train and then and then he goes
like absolutely just ate nuts and
attacks this guy he stalks him around
the train station for a bit and then
assaults him a train blows up and then
she watches her she watches him get hit
by a cargo train like feet away from her
I'm not going to show you a video of
what that would actually look like but
uh needless to say that's not gonna be
pretty
this woman is now like quadruple
traumatized in her universe her friend
just told the future her friend just
died in front of her she narrowly
escaped death and now the city that she
lives in is gonna be nuked in like you
know a few hours like later that
afternoon her hometown is gonna get
nuked and and that's just gonna like
she's she was better off dead so you've
got that that universe ends up being you
know I mean it doesn't really go all
that different but her life uh gets yeah
her life gets a little bit a little bit
messed up okay so the big one is of
course the one at the end of the movie
this is not a happy ending okay first
let's talk about the moral implications
of this Sean Fentress died on the train
and the source-code project essentially
allows them to take someone else's
consciousness you know what let's just
call it a soul we're just gonna use the
word soul here and we're gonna say that
source code lets them take someone's
soul and move it into another person's
body so they've taken captain Colter
Stevens and they've they've moved his
soul into the body of Sean Fentress so
at that moment Sean Fentress as a as a
personality and as an
identity ceased to exist his body is
still around and people still know him
but he as a person is not there this
person is for all intents and purposes
now captain Colter Stevens where this
goes bad is is basically the next day
he's learned a little bit about her and
he's learned enough about their
situation that he's able to converse
with her about their their immediate
circumstances but there's a ton of other
things that he doesn't know so there's
all the stuff that Shawn knew that he's
now gonna have to just fake his way
through he doesn't have the benefit of
repeats anymore he's not in a game
anymore he's now back into the flow of
normal life he doesn't have the chance
to like be like oh well what do you
think about this you know he doesn't
have Groundhog Day mechanics here he
doesn't have video game mechanics he
doesn't get redos do-overs or or second
tries if he doesn't know something
people are gonna notice you know it has
the same kind of dark implications as
Groundhog Day and back to the future
because we now have this guy who is
living a life that he knows nothing
about now this is actually almost worse
than Back to the Future
you know Back to the Future has got some
serious problems because Marty McFly
he's suddenly everything he knows about
his world is different everything he
knows about his family he has all these
memories that that basically don't exist
but he's still him in this case a
person's personality has completely
altered overnight so the next day is
when this seriously seriously kind of
kind of goes to crap because he can't
just not go to work Sean Fentress he's a
teacher
I mean it's implied that he's teaching
it like a university or a college level
you know one of those levels of
education where you're expected to know
what you're talking about
he's not just a high school teacher and
even if he was you know there there's a
certain level of he doesn't know his
family his coworkers where he lives what
his car looks it doesn't even take until
the next day it's gonna be later that
day when he goes oh crap I I don't know
who I am do I have like deadly allergies
what's my mom's name there's all of
these questions about
he's a trained soldier who's now living
the life of of a history teacher this is
not going to go well for him you know we
saw a lot of this Marty McFly like he
had all these fake memories Marty was
kind of he was screwed in the D had all
of these fake memories that didn't that
never happened or didn't exist about
people who who are like completely
different personalities now but Shawn
with Colter Stevens living inside of his
body Colter can actually like he's got
buddies that he can call up he can call
up people and be like yo I know you and
they'll be like and he's got these
details he knows these these people's
lives and he can confirm just about
everything that that he now believes but
let's say hypothetically you know like
if he had a house and he had a a spare
key like hidden in the back garden well
okay I guess I guess he was called he
was dead and they reported him dead he
knows where that key is and he can be
like hey let's let's go visit this place
that I know intimately we're gonna go
into this backyard I'm gonna find this
key and it's gonna open the door and I'm
gonna be able to tell you like
everything that's inside this house and
they're gonna be like how do you know
all this stuff and he'll be like I don't
know and they'll be like well why you're
you're Sean Fentress I mean like look at
your ID or your mom
everybody knows you you're you're Sean
Fentress but you don't know any of our
names you you know nothing about your
job you don't you know nothing about
your own life but you know all this
other stuff
um witchcraft every time there's
something where they have to pull out
source code it's probably inevitably
going to end with a culture Stevens not
dying in the event you know succeeding
in some way and managing to keep himself
alive to the point that he has now taken
over that person's existence after ten
ten or seven or thirty some like a huge
number of successful source codes you're
going to have like just as many culture
Stevens's in the world all of these
culture Stevens is like trying to
I went what happened in their lives and
how each of them is like yeah I I blew
up in Afghanistan and then all of a
sudden I was in this dude's body you ate
his soul and took his body they'll
they'll need to invent an entirely new
are so that's it for this week tune in
next week for something that we haven't
decided
just roll the clip